i don't consider myself a particularly
ethical person no but i am fair
[Music]
based on the true story of the
family-run gucci fashion empire lady
gaga's new role sees her play patricia
reggiani who in 1998 was found guilty of
hiring a hitman to carry out the
cold-blooded assassination of her
husband
[Laughter]
to say that the guccis were complicated
would be a massive understatement
i you know it's amazing you know how you
say
things like uh you can't make this up uh
the the truth about this whole story is
you watch it and it's actually
unbelievable that it's true historically
actually we hear a lot about women from
sort of more working-class backgrounds
having to sort of hustle to to find
their position because we we live in a
man's world don't we i mean is that more
how you saw it then she was hustling to
to get ahead what was fascinating to me
was that i didn't actually believe ever
that patricia gucci was a gold digger
just because this woman was lower class
than the gucci's and wanted better for
herself it doesn't make her a hustler in
a negative way there's this illusion of
power that like you said in a
patriarchal society and in this
patriarchal system was actually just a
total illusion because as soon as they
said this is not a girl's game patrizia
uh
her whole house of cards begins to fall
we can't justify what she did though i
have no interest in trying to make a
case for why this should have happened i
don't believe this should have happened
it's it's reprehensible it's horrible
and when this murder took place i
believe it happened because she was so
traumatized so hurt that she made a
terrible
awful mistake
that she deeply regrets known as a
world-leading music and fashion icon
gaga is a rare beast capable of winning
both grammys and oscars switching
seamlessly from pop diva to performing
under the direction of ridley scott i
felt so empowered as a woman on a set
with mostly men and i felt loved
he's he's an absolute legend and he's
masterful at what he does he
is has as a process is like an architect
you know and he like he describes the
script as the blueprint gaga's music
outfits might speak to a vivid
imagination but the singer who has
spoken about being raped by a male music
producer when she was 19 says she drew
on the darker side of her life to make
her character feel real
when i think about my real life
experiences there was a lot of things
that i've been through in my life
traumatic experiences that i drew upon
to play patrizia and
it's not necessarily imaginative i guess
in that way meaning i'm i'm calling upon
myself
now it might be imaginative to you you
might see it and say oh that that that
looks like it possesses imagination
but for me it's it's not imaginative
it's real
have you let go of her yet in a way i
have fully let go of her like ran from
her because she
she was so broken at the end of filming
and
i was so broken at the end of filming
and it's emotional because i'm an
italian-american woman and my family's
from italy and my family worked
so hard on the soil that we filmed this
movie on
so that i could have a better life and
here i am talking to you about starring
in a ridley scott film
this is a real honor and i'm really
grateful gaga's eccentricities might
make her the focus of fascination in
real life but strip away the costumes
and wigs and to her latest role on
screen she brings a gripping intensity
katie spencer sky news